[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
domino
domino le printemps chante en moi
Dominique le soleil c'est fait beau j'ai
le cœur comme une boîte à musieque
j'ai besoin de toi de tes mains sur moi
de ton corps doux et chaud j'ai envie
d'être aimé domino il est une pensée que
je ne souffre pas c'est qu'on puisse me
prendre ma place en tes bras je
supporte bien des choses mais à force
CEN est trop et qu'un autre a l'idée de
me voler mon bien je ne donne pas chair
de tes jours et des siens je reg regarde
qui
t'entour prend bien
garde mon
amour
domino
domino j'ai bien tort de me mettre en
colère avec toi domino
je sais trop qu'il n'y a rien à faire tu
as le cœur
légé tu ne peux
changer mais je t'aime que
veux-tu je ne peux pas changer moi non
plus
domino
domino je pardonne toujours mais reviens
et je ne te
dirai plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien